dix minutes avant la sortie des classes
il arrive comme d'habitude à vélo tous
les jours c'est le même rituel
les trois agents de médiation de la
commune du vauclin se positionne aux
abords du collège et ça me paraît
peut-être pas mais leur travail a déjà
commencé et échanger un pas entre les
jeunes et nous mêmes qui fait que si un
problème vont viennent vers nous on a
discuté avec les élèves leurs parents le
personnel éducatif c'est l'une de leurs
principales missions
parce que leur seule présence est
souvent dissuasive et rassurante
c'est aux abords des collèges on sait
pas ce qui se passait ça peut être au
niveau d'autres qui viennent pour donner
de la drogue et tout on sait jamais
alors ça me rassure il ya des petits
combats d'heure des élèves qui se sont
donc ils sont là pour calmer canaliser
mon séparés puis pour les inciter à
rentrer chez eux avec quelques mètres
plus loin c'est au niveau de la place
des fêtes que les médiateurs font leur
ronde
tapez tapez activités faire bander dans
un endroit stratégique où les problèmes
de petite délinquance sont courants et
pas qu'avec les élèves
est ce que vous vous pouvez intervenir
oui on commence on va dire qu'on
mais c'est de désamorcer si on ne peut
pas on les sent pas seul chambaud au
sommet contre t'opposes création d'
équipe de médiation mise en place de
vidéosurveillance travail avec les
associations
autant de dispositifs pour lutter contre
la délinquance est aujourd'hui l'heure
était au bilan à la mairie entre 2016 et
2017 la délinquance aurait baissé de 25%
sur le territoire la délinquance baisse
au vauclin les atteintes aux biens et
aux personnes s et puis une application
de plus en plus importante des acteurs
de la population puisque les
associations participent la population
vient anticipe pose des questions on
fait des suggestions et pour nous c'est
très positif parce qu'on va dans le bon
sens
prochaine étape pour ce conseil local
s'attaquer aux violences domestiques qui
reste encore beaucoup trop importante
dans la commune